voilà alors on voit des photos on va
voir par exemple voilà ce canapé on va
voir la photo mettez la photo où les
enfants voilà jouent parce qu'on vra
qu'on avait vu des des voilà donc non
c'est pas celui-là c'est l'autre merci
deuxème deuxème photo voilà donc c'est
vrai que voilà tout le monde a dit voilà
c'est l'endroit où ù ils ont une vie
familiale alors c'est vrai que ça fait
énormément parlé il y a eu je ne sais
plus combien de vues je crois que 34
millions de
vues si si toi Guillaume tu es
extrêmement choqué on va voir la
réaction du fils de 17 ans dans un
instant jeis justeant faire un tour
deable j'ai d'autres ex comment ne pas
être choqué on a une mère de famille un
père de famille qui ont des enfants qui
sont tous mineurs et très très jeunes
qui sont quand même en train de faire
une sex tapape au calme sur un canapé le
même canapé sur lequel les enfants vont
garder midi les zouous le lendemain
matin c'est extrêmement choquant non
mais en vrai et ce qui m'exaspère c'est
cet argument des vidéos privées parce
qu'à la rigueur vous êtes acteur pour
nous c'est un choix de vie vous rendez
tout ça public là ils disent non mais
c'est privé donc on peut avoir une vie
normale et se cacher derrière ça mais la
vérité c'est que les gens ils sont mal
intentionnés vous croyez quoi le mec qui
va payer sa vidéo ou sa photo 30 balles
ball qu'est-ce qu'ils font les gens ils
screenent avec un autre téléphone et les
vidéos elles se retrouvent sur les les
réseaux sociaux donc la vérité c'est que
ta dignité elle va 61000 vues sur la
vidéo du mais 34 millions sur les
réseauxou mais là la vidéo elle renifle
des chaussettes ou je sais pas quoi 30 €
30 € le gars il prend une photo avec son
téléphone il le met sur Twitter
d'ailleurs il le savent ils ont réagi la
dernière fois il y a déjà des vidéos qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux donc
ça veut dire que ta dignité vaut 30 € il
faut arrêter le massacre pour les
enfants c'est irresponsable évite c'est
extrêmement dangereux ce qu'ils font
alors je vais vous montrer d'autres
extraits dans quelques instants Kelly
moi je suis trop fâché parce que c'est
une c'est une enfin moi je l'ai regardé
l'émission et c'est une famille à
laquelle on s'était attaché ils étaent
un peu barrés un peu bargeot mais c'est
ça qui les rendait attachant justement
ouais voilà ils étaient vachement
chouette et maintenant de voir des des
choses comme ça B moi je suis déçu parce
qu'en fait ils disent oui mais on on on
met on cache tout ça on le fait quand
ils sont à l'école mais il y a quand
même une ambiance assez malsène parce
que quand on voit qu'ils rangent leurs
instruments de torture à l'intérieur du
canapé je veux dire des enfants ça
jouent ça ça fout le bazar les les
canapés sont toujours à la fin de la
journée à moié si mon fils me demande
d'aller jouer chez leurs filles je
dirai les C sont toujours à la ramasse à
la fin de la journée bon bah qui dit pas
que le petit de 4 ans la petite de 5 ans
elle va pas se retrouver avec des gotes
dans la main et des trucs comme ça enfin
raison bien sûr elle a raison
oui j'entends ce que dit Kelly et moi je
trouve que je les soutiens vraiment mais
je trouve qu'ils vont sans doute un peu
loin là dans ce très bon reportage je
les soutiens mais par rapport à ce que
dit Guillaume c'estàd qu' il met oui il
faut leur retirer la garde c'est ça la
question Guillaume leur retirer la garde
quel délit quel juge des enfants dé ID
de ça qui êtes-vous mon cher Guillaume
pour priver autant d'enfants de leurs
parents dont ils ont besoin donc qu'on
puisse avoir une posture morale en
disant c'est trop ça va trop loin mais
retirer la garde non et je dénonce
également l'acharnement dont ils sont
victimes sur les réseaux il y a pas de
dél C il y a pas de dél oui non mais moi
effectivement mais je suis comme toi ça
me fa ça ça me voilà ça me choque parce
que c'est pas ma conception de la vie
enfin voilà mais pour autant je vais pas
moi me mettre en en mer la morale en
décidant que qu'ils ont droit qu'il n
pas le droit la question c'est est-ce
que ça tombe sous le coup de la loi ou
pas pour l'instant ça ne tombe pas sous
le coup de la loi deuxième question
c'est est-ce que ça met les enfants en
danger là je dis que effectivement ça
peut mettre les enfants en danger parce
que ces vidéos vont circuler parce que
dans les cours de récréation ils vont
pouvoir peut-être se faire tabasser
parce qu'on va dire ta mère elle fait c
ta mère elle fait ça et cetera et en
l'occurrence moi je pense que pour
résoudre ce problème-là de des enfants
euh leur retirer la garde c'est
extrêmement euh lointain enfin énorme
comme comme décision mais que que des
services sociaux viennent réguliè iéf
comment les enants comment est la maison
est-ce que tout le monde va bien est-ce
qu'il un suivi psychologique et mais
retir immédiatement la
gé je
peux oui juste Guillaume tu fais quoi
des des gens qui ont fait du porno comme
comme métier des femmes non mais c'est
attends ça laisse la même la même
empreinte sur le net plus fort s'il vous
plaî c'est la même chose après je suis
d'accord qu'ils vont un peu loin parce
qu'ils vont voilà ils vont il s'est un
peu trop poussé mais quand quand tu as
une carrière
travaille là o dit n'importe quoi tu dis
n'importe quoi parce que les acteurs et
les actrices de film porno ils se
protègent ils ont compris vite fait que
leurs enfants il fallait les protéger
alors soit ils avaient pas d'enfants
quand ils ont fait du porno soit quand
ils ont des enfants font pas des vidéos
ils ont pas fait une émission sur TF
regardé par des mil V les enfants des
acteurs porno et des actrices porno tu
les connais pas
tu les connaisi mais nous on les conna
pasis grand public conna pas les
enants em sur le net c'est même
chose mais justement en fait acteur
porno c'est un choix de vie qui est
risqué cert mais moi ce qui me fait
pe c'est qu'ils n'ont pas conscience de
ce qu'ils font qu tu les écoutes parler
déjà il y a pas un mot pas une pensée
pour les enfants il y a des enfants je
crois qui ont 3 ou 4 ans il y a pas une
pensée pour eux de ce que vont devenir
ces vidéos plus tard et comment ils vont
le vivre ils nont pas
conscience ils n'ont pas conscience de
compr pas on ne comprend
rien
comprend tu veux dire argument comprend
mais rien il y a pas d'argument
qu'est-ce que tu voulais dire je vous le
redis vous parlez de effectivement
gueule articule c'est vrai articu quand
tu pètes là on a bien compris là non je
disais l'empreinte sur les réseaux et la
M ta gueule toi aussi
[Applaudissements]
merde possible donc eux ils vont
beaucoup trop loin une intervention par
émission et tu la foires tu parles une
fois et tu foires tout c'est pas
possible [__] tu pas droit pour être
là je vais demander au chef
moi vas-y vas-y le tur de chat
exprime-toi
[Applaudissements]
vas-y donc effectivement eux vont trop
loin mais quand tu as une carrière de X
dans le X femme ou homme excuse-moi tu
as la même empreinte sur le
net tu sais bien attends les enfants de
Rif s'app comment
questionis tu connais les enfants de
business
le grand public con il dit n Il sa qu'il
a fait une connerie quand il pas du tout
pas du tout on VO excuse-toi comme pour
les chatsexcuse pas es mauvais en chat
et en
chat non mais pardon parce qu'on se
marre mais moi en fait j'ai envie de
chaler parce que je trouve ça
tellement mais c'est par rapport c'est
par rapport à la prestation de
Benjamin c'est c'est catastrophique non
non mais non je veux dire en fait c'est
tellement Glo c'est tellement sordide
c'est tellement grandeur et décadence
mais pardonnez-moi mais moi je trouve
que c'est absolument gerbant moi je m'en
fous de la pornographie ils font ce
qu'ils veulent de leur vie privée mais
le problème que on les connaît grâce à
leurs enfants leurs enfants c'est le P
c'est le COD vie c'est leur assurance
vie donc aujourd'hui pour moi c'est des
non assistance à personnees en danger et
je pense pardonnez-moi je pense que si
on continue à médiatiser ce qui va se
passer peut-être qu'il y a des services
sociaux qui vont quand même se pencher
sur le cas de ses enfants et je trouve
que ce serait très bien parce que bien
sûr qu'ils vont se faire harceler parce
que l'autre jour elle est venue elle
nous a dit non mais on vit dans un petit
village c'est cool c'est sympathique
mais dans les petits villages on harcèle
comme dans les grands villages le petit
Lucas qui s'est qui s'est donné la mort
c'était un petit village donc il faut
arrêter avec ça c'est quand même un
scandale absolu alors tu verras la
réaction de Léo dans un instant leur
fils de de 17 ans on a l'extrait juste
je vous dis on vous a posé la question
sur les réseaux il y a 70 % de gens pour
l'instant qui disent qu'il faut le
retirer la
GAR mais encore une fois je pense qu'il
faut voilà faut pas cracher sur les
acteurs porno faut juste pas banaliser
ça faut être conscient des conséquences
et moi ce qui me fait très peur avec eux
c'est que quand vous leur parlez vous le
dites vous êtes acteurs porno non non
c'est un travail on est dans on est dans
l'influence digitale prendre son cul en
selie c'est pas
travailler travaill non mais c'est vrai
ce n'est pas un travail pas travi tout à
l'heure je suis désolé travaill et ça a
des conséquences dramatiques les vidéos
elles restent elles tournent et ce qui
est encore plus pervers la différence
avec un acteur porno c'est que eux ils
se sont formé une image avec ça non mais
ils se sont formé ils se sont forgés une
image familiale avec une émission qui a
duré effectivement pendant
s
ternoent
dansno suis d'accord jeis d'accord vous
parez des enfants que l'on repère pas
mais si ilst ils ont passé des semaines
entières sur TF1 tout le monde les
connait ces enfants donc ils vont être
harcelés à l'école forcément il faut pas
rêver c'est ça qui est
scandal ad ils font ce qu'ils veulent
entre adultes mais là les pauvres
enfants et ça c'est de la maltraitante
psychologique qui est condamnable par un
Justus c'est pour ça qu'ils ont intérêt
à faire attention la la justice peut le
tomber dus surtout que là le soir même
en toute honnêteté et on l'a tous fait
et je regarde des personnes voilà on l'a
tous fait autour de la table vous
cherchez en 2 secondes vous trouvez les
vidéos porno de ces de ces deux
personnes donc on est on les ses enfants
là ils vont avoir combien dans
2 dans 2 3 ans ils vont avoir l'âge de
chercher sur internet et ben en deux
clics ils vont trouver leurs parents euh
sur les les sites en train de faire
devra
pas et là on a beau nous dire oui mais
je parlerai avec mes enfants au moment
venu B non en fait parce qu'ils auront
vu la vidéo déjà avant que tu leur en
parles vous allez voir la réaction de
Léo 17 ans dans un instant qui était sur
le tournage Daniel je t'ai pas entendu
làdus SP non moi je suis écuré j'ai mis
non parce que les parents méritent qu'on
leur retire leurs enfants je trouve là
en voyant ça mais les enfants ne
méritent pas qu'on leur enlève leurs
parents je pense qu'ils continuent à les
aimer et ça serait encore plus
traumatisant si on leur enlevait leurs
parents donc il faut vraiment que les
réseau les assistantes sociales soient
très très vigilant parce que là je elle
me fait presque de la peine je pense
qu'elle est dans sur une pente elle a
envie de lumière on le voit bien comme
elle le prend à la légère comm pour
l'instant de la lumièreelle CL torche
non mais c'est vrai j'ai presque envie
de l'Indre mais voilà il faut vraiment
que les les
assistants parce qu'ils sont
fort Ilim pas le mal non plus si vous
nous rejoignez à 20h43 la famille piss
vous la connaissez si vous connaissiez
famill nombreuses sur TF1 et c'est vrai
que voilà ils ont gagné en très peu de
temps 20
6242 € 55 centimes je leur fait cadeau
des 55 centimes pour avec leur vidéo
porno Gill ça ça te donne des idées je
sais que toi tu es un petit peu
réra je pense que castal la
comp il y a une demande folle pour leurs
activités encore une fois moi que que je
cautionne pas c'est énorme c'est des
sommes considérables ça c'est la
première chose et la deuxième chose je
le redis j'entends dire que maltraitance
enfant retirer la gare je crois que vous
ne vous rendez pas bien compte de ce que
vous êtes en train de dire c'està-dire
que vous voudriez les déchoir de leur
autorité
parentale pour des vidéos pour des
vidéos comme ça et et Cyril va le
montrer pour le moment l'enfant de 17
ans l'ado qui a réagi il n'est pas
contre ça donc vous vous présupposez des
choses qui n'existent pas et moi je
trouve ça hyper violent pour eux voilà
toi qui est violent pour nous hein quoi
c'est lui qui est violent pour nous de
dire ça est pas sousemprise' dit pas ça
parce d'argent là là là là on a mis le
doigt sur
excusez-moi on a soulevé un problème
c'est qu'en vrai les gars il y a
énormément d'argent après c'est l'ronage
comment vous faites après pour arrêter
en vrai c'est vrai quand moment tu
gagnes depuis décembre ils ont gagné
26000 € depuis décembre c'est
énormissime comment tu fais pour arrêter
après la vie change et même les enfants
en vrai ils se disent bah attends nous
mine de rien papa ils vont pouvoir
acheter Demer plus plus horrible on sait
pas ser quoi la nouvelle limite en fait
mais ellea dit elle l'a dit elle a dit à
un moment donné oui je sais je sais pas
parce qu'en fait on a tellement de
demandes qu'on pensait pas aller si loin
mais du coup on va on a encore un peu de
de frein mais on sait pas en fait elle
le dit elle-même que qu'à la base elle
comptait pas aller si loin don dans tous
les cas elle dit c'est l'offre et la
demande on a beaucoup de demandes mais
ou mais comme je dis au téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent et qui on est en
direct c'est vrai que cette affaire vous
allez voir la vie du fils Léo le fils
aîné de 17 ans aujourd'hui à un moment
quand tu es dans un engrenage comme ça
quand tu as pris 25 26 ur en 2 mois
comment tu fais pour t'arrêter tu peux
pas t'arrêter tu te dis attends c'est
c'est vrai c'est la course après tu en
plus après tu tu augmentes ton niveau de
vie les enfants ils disent bah non bah
grâce à papa et maman maintenant on
kiffe encore plus parce que c'est une
famille nombreuse et je peux vous dire
que ils avaient comme on l'a vu
d'ailleurs dans les reportages c'était
compliqué pour eux là aujourd'hui ils
disent mais attendez on va aller on va
gagner on peut gagner presque 15000 €
par mois oui des ch de pire en pire
aussi pas que les chaettes
sales et la meilleure solution pardon
mais c'est de ne pas commencer Gill
comment tu peux soulever cet argument
dire vous rendez compte c'est beaucoup
d'argent mais c'est
n'imporo où il se trahent qu'est-ce qu'
disait la dernière fois nous on fait ça
par plaisir parce qu'on faisait déjà ça
dans le vie qu' ok on fait des vidéos
dégueulasses mais regardez il y a 26000
€ al déjà pardon 26000 € cert c'est une
énorme somme ça va pas changer le vie
plus voiture voiture ça changera JAMA
B secondi secondes mais attendez
attendez arrêtez arrz non mais comment
je peux entendre des inepsie pareil sur
un plateau les mecs 26000 € en un mois
ça veut dire qu'ils peuvent faire 200000
€ par an ça va
ch ça an s prennent 50000 € qu's ont
traumatisé leurs enfants00
est
vraiment pourar
mal dis il le disait avant il avent des
aid et maintenant il gagnent trop
d'argent pour avoir les aides donc ça
remplace les aides qu'il av plus
les pas 26000 € d' mais mais c'est en
plus voilà c'est en
plus me somme d'argent maintenant est-ce
que la dignité de deux parents et de H
enfantème s'en fout il sont maintenant
dans
l'engrenage
parroi les limit ENIT don alors pour
50000 tu te prostitues moi oui oui moi
oui si on le donne 100000 alors est-
pour balles
just est- que le fils de 17 ans caméra
ouais non mais sera quoi la limite alors
alors justement leur limite actuelle
c'est d'avoir des rapports payés voilà
donc il refuse la prostitution il refuse
de on leur a proposé des choses entre
coupes aussi payé ils l'ont refusé pour
le moment ça c'est la limite mais le
problème c'est qu'ils avait déjà la
limite du porno donc est-ce que là ils
vont pas accepter justement ce genre de
de proposition on sait pas alors on va
voir beaucoup se demandent est-ce que
Léo le fils aîné de la famille pense des
pratiques de ses parents ce dernier a
répondu aux questions de Jerem star
regardez la vie du fils du Saint-Esprit
amen amen dans l'aventure c'est vrai que
on s'est dit quand même comme léo est en
âge bah peut-être voilà d'être au
courant de voir passer des choses sur
Internet ou quoi on s'est dit on va lui
demander avant de se lancer là-dedans si
Léo avait mis un véau on l'aurait
peut-être pas fait après voilà il nous a
donné son aval c'est rare que les
parents donent la permission à un gamin
pour faire quelque chose quand même mais
voilà chez nous ça arrive quoi jamais
personne emmerde Léo jamais personne
s'est foutu de lui la harcelé ou
harceler les gosses donc évidemment
c'est un jour ça mettait nos enfants en
souffrance là la question se poserait
pas mais mais par que par exemple genre
vous lui avez enfin ils te l'ont dit
comment naturellement qu on mangeait
puis ils m'ont dit que voilà ils
aimeraient bien commencer ça je leurais
dit B si vous voulez hein si vous vous
amusez bah tant mieux c'est bien
voilà c'est laacodique quand même he si
vous vous amusez tant mieux on peut pas
dire qu'il soit très emballé quand même
papa ce garçon en plus c'est pas son
papa he celui qui joue dans les vidéos
he c'est le premier ouis le premier
c'est
c'est ah oui ouais l'aîné effectivement
c'est pas le fils de ce monsieur voilà
ça peut choquer je disais ça peut
choquer que je dise non il faut pas
enlever les enfants parce que moi je
pense aux enfants vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure exact imaginez parce qu'après ça
va être des familles d'accueil ils vont
tous être
dispersés c'est uniquement pour ça qu'on
dit parce que franement je préciser
parce ça choque beaucoup alors g il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ont été choqués en
disant regardez-le il a l'air triste il
a l'air presque contraint entre ses deux
parents et et mais je là on présuppose
une contrainte et tout ça franchement
ils regardent à un moment la caméra ils
disent ce qu'il pens et moi j'ai été
choqué encore une fois de l'acharnement
contre lui en disant il pense pas ce
qu'il dit on l'a forcé à dire ça ah il y
a eu ça sur les réseaux je suis c'est
qu'on a peur pour lui parce que
effectivement pardon moi je suis maire
de famille je vois ce garçon je vois ce
garçon qui regarde pas franchement la
caméra qui se qui se met la main devant
la bouche parce que il dit quelque chose
et on a le sentiment quand on met la
main devant la bouche en générale c'est
qu'on pense pas réellement ce qu'on dit
tu es beau
Castaldi intelligent tu es intelligent
Casta et que moi j'ai l'impression de
voir un garçon un peu paomé qui a envie
de faire plaisir à sa maman et qui veut
pas la contrarier c'est voà donc on a le
droit d'avoir peur pour lui c'est tout
on a le droit d'avoir peur pour ce gosse
excuse-moi face caméra qu'est-ce que tu
voulais qu'il dise il allait désavouer
ses parents là face caméra il est
évidemment obligé et ça et cette scèneel
est encore plus malaisante que toutes
les autres que ce gamin soit obligé de
d'approuver quelque chose comme ça fasse
caméra ça ça m' cur encore plus je crois
que les les culottes souillé et les
chaussettes Sal et pourtant die sais que
j'ai envie de vomir he oui alors
attention cé voilà non mais je je te le
dis regardez le sondage on va voir ce
que vous en pensez chez vous oui à 70 %
rendez compte non non à 70 % g qu tu
réponds aux gens voilà qui disent que
qui disent oui à 70 % en fait ils ont
une posture morale c'est pas bien ce
qu'on voit ça peut choquer et ceetera
mais retirer la carte des enfants
excusez-moi je vais employer un mot
c'est criminel c'est briser une famille
et ca et cette famille ne me paraît pas
sur le point d'être brisé donc moi je
crois à la parole de cet ado de 17 ans
qui a dit ce qu'il pensait je ne crois
pas qu'il ait été contraint c'est pas
très bien ce qu'ils font je suis
d'accord ça pe ch en a h autres des
enfants c'est ça le problème aut oui
mais de mais de là a brisé une famille
je dis non voilà qu'on leur laisse leurs
enfants là on entend celui de 17 ans je
te crois CELI de 17 ans il est content
il est d'accord il boit du café qui
existe même pas il fait trois fois de
café il y a pas de café dans la tasse il
est bien il est bien je te crois je te
crois maintenant comme a dit Kelly il y
en a hut derrière on pas autes on n pas
le retour de ce qui va se passer quand
ils auront 8 ans 7 ans 10 ans on sait
pas alors vous si vous voulez peut-être
5 26000 50000 € 70000 € il vont les
bouffer en 2 ans ou a 8 autres ils vont
les bouffer l'argent ils vont le bouffer
en 2 ans et derrière les dégâts ça se
trouve ça va être considérable vous
pouvez pas savoir moi je trouve que
c'est dangereux mais je veux pas
qu'on pas qu'on le
rere c'est quand même dangereux ce qu'il
font je pense que les services sociaux
vont quand même venir jeter un
surtout c'est vrai voilà oui y afant
derrière bah c'est sûr que lion voilà
bah oui c'est de la
lion